oh mio dio ho cambiato un'impostazione
ragazzi che cazzo è successo è diventato
aramaico antico mettiamo mi sto
scherzando
scherzavo aiuto mi sono calmata
mi sono calmato l tutti ragazzi e poi
venuti avessimo video sono vari geni che
ci siamo trovati sud foreste passano
tipo un anno la luce volta che ho fatto
un episodio di the forest sarà cambiato
tipo tutto ragazzi volo televisione
cotoletta che cazzo possono richiedere
di più
no cosa noi che misys minchia la tutto
letta ma cosa cazzo fate gli incidenti
aerei bar dal riso per te raccoglie non
supera che stare in nero tranquilli vi
denuncio appena scendiamo giuro e vabbè
ma conto letto ormai a [ __ ] ragazzi
niente da fare c'è sempre il vostro ecco
ma per questo questo è rimasto nei
secoli a un gomito al bambino non l'ho
mica visto l'importante è che sia
contento lui poi vabbè concreta eccola
qua eccola qui dio mio almeno sei
minchiata l'importante questo perché
siano morte delle persone rob e fotte
sega basta che la cotoletta sia salva ma
ciao zio è tutto a posto ma fatti come
quando io faccio i salti fa così con la
mano i no age ii e juan che cos'è un
altra asciano ramo perfetto allora
ragazzi siamo tornati come i vecchi
tempi mi sembra veramente strano di
giocare a the forest è veramente assurdo
c'è un coniglio rea c'è un coniglio mi
sa che mi l'ascolta se invece di farti
le pipe per imparare a cacciare i coni
dove equa bastardo scolta zio non
scappare no scappare che lo zio favi e
amico tuo niente o non c'è verso non lo
prendono mai nella vita giacosa guardali
guardali gigi è allora sei stupido
l'ho preso l'ho preso l'ho fatta è morto
si è morto perfetto lega basta sono
orgoglioso importanti ragazzi andare
avanti cosa c'è gollum
il mio tesoro l'ho trovato io sul fiume
ragazzi dove vi giuro che l'ho visto non
lo sono sognato c'è l'altra parte
dell'aereo lega che culo che è rimasta
sull'isola fantastico c'è un tizio morto
dentro probabilmente gollum si è
avvicinato a vedere che cazzo successo
padrone rimasto ferito nello schianto
aereo a ti piacerebbe che fosse rimasto
ferito stronzo sono ancora vivo non ho
mai trovate io sta parte dell'aereo no
madonna zio non hai una bella cera
ascolta frate c'è gollum che si aggira
da queste parti quindi fate attenzione
io vi foto la roba me ne vado grazie
mille molto gentili che per caso nei
primi che ciò fa ho trovato la pistola
ragazzi sono a posto ho trovato la
[ __ ] pistola spara dardi se non
killer adesso percordo ragazzi devo toni
smigol prima che è un sasso bambini mi
riguarda mi dove vai no no no scappare
non scappare lo star da cos'è veramente
chi è che ha messo sta cosa qua o di una
corda per arrampicarsi ma c'è qualcuno
no no che c'è bambi cazzo mette fatto
perdere bah mi sono distratto lurido
bandi di merda e la madonna che trick
bastardo niente la mancata non ce la
farò mai ragazze invece si è uccidere
bambi affanculo roberta stavo scherzando
ragazzi è tutto vostro
è tutto vostro brega io me la tua gambe
via via via via meno eccoci siamo co2
calarmi giu regalo calarmi giu per forza
dai vai vai vai vai vai
oddio mi dicono che se usarla una corda
per scalare sono morto così che bel so
ancora vivo come sono ancora vivo
ragazzi sono 18 fantastico ma non posso
salire perché non so salire la corda
porca put a salve è che bello che sei
veramente un figo ragazzi siamo nelle
caverne però c'è un'uscita dal tetto non
è mai successo ma costa e salame milano
si prende al supermercato 9 ros
equipaggiarla l'arma grazie a dio
se vedo qualcuno li faccio saltare il
cervello ve lo dico che ci sono i
carrelli siamo ad esselunga ragazzi
l'importante è uscire da trovare una
[ __ ] torcia non faccio 2 metri ve lo
dico sto sentendo dell'acqua che scorre
rega non so dove ma c'è un uomo che non
è proprio comodo qua ho trovato una
mappa mappa 3d quattro collezioni ci
sono le mappe in questo gioco di preciso
dove stiamo andando
così un altro ancora ma chi cazzo è che
si metta a scala che fa no no non lo zio
no non hai capito non scendere un kayak
non sono caduto
grazie a dio era basso da bene ci stiamo
calando sempre di più qua sotto la cosa
non è che mi entusiasma più di tanto
però vabbè dai fan culo portiamo sta
nella mordor questo ragazzi smigol ecco
cazzo cazzo cazzo ma [ __ ] di
organi è morto non è morto è morto che
cazzo fai balliamo accadere morto zucca
zucca zucca il testare mia posso
prendere il cad a macomer sta cosa il
geniale cazzo c'era solo un gol vero non
più di uno perché sennò col cazzo che
che bel culo sexy che c'hai cos'è
barrette energetiche che botta di culo
assurda by che c'hai mars fantastico
piano dei denti fantasy deve essere un
dentista ragazzi a tempo perso gollum
che cosa di più del cazzo stia mandando
liga
vedo una luce è un tè un teschio ma come
essere o non essere una lampada non sei
una lampada se un teschio se c'è qualcun
altro ragazzi tiro giù tutto il mondo
dove siamo quest'anno sempre
rigorosamente più in basso cos'è quella
merda frega
c'è una gamba e voi avete persona gamma
ragazzi spegne l'accendino grazie al
piano piace cazzo oddio santo
marta 2 cazzo vado ragazzi sta
avvicinando perché mi stai venendo
addosso lurido porco l'ho mai visto vero
ma visto cazzo ma visto allo sbaraglio
[Applauso]
barca [ __ ] vacca che blocca che sei
non mi ha ucciso perfetta da corri corri
corri corri corri corri corri corri
corri corri fare spedizione mi ha ucciso
come che ho fatto non uccidermi ero
convintissimo di s chi è che lancia i
bambini amico mio è una specie di gara
del lancio
porca [ __ ] ucciso sono stato ucciso
da un poppante che non era neanche così
bello poi cazzo hai tu vai via dai
ragazzi sopravvissuto 0 giorni vero sono
un pro gamer di queste cose dai ragazzi
di partiamo come si deve perché mica
prima è stata tragedia trovato una palla
da tennis tra l'altro dove posso andare
fatevi trovare sta minchia di spiaggia
vi prego che ogni [ __ ] volta non la
trovo mai che poi tra l'altro che è una
donna che albero stavo scherzando
ragazzi
ok ciao cosa fate ragazzi giocate a
nascondino guarda tenuti trova nessuno
eh sì nascosto benissimo fico la testa
nel terreno e bellissimo cazzo è la
spiaggia ogni volta eccola ma no non ho
neanche capito bene se quella dell'altra
volta o se un'altra diversa però ci sono
degli squali sono degli squali morti per
terra che bello ragazzi di gesù
moltiplicava i pesci io moltiplica gli
squali e una mia dote o moltiplicato uno
squalo semplicemente toccandolo va bene
prendetene mangiatene tutti e con tanto
di palla da boe da tennis ma che cos'è
il nuovo victoria secret che ha aperto
sull'isola fantastico ok ragazzi ci
siamo o equipaggiato questa perché mi sa
di arma molto più violenta rispetto a
quella di prima alve c'è per caso
qualcuno ce che era per fare più veloce
ma da ke pigri ragazzi non vedo niente
zero
sto camminando veramente a vuoto spero
di non incontrare qualcuno che mi uccide
come niente qualche [ __ ] ma
[ __ ]
c'è gente c'è già
e che cazzo è la mia vita lurido porco
vieni vieni basta vieni vieni qua è che
cazzo eva sono morta e lega ma cosa ma
come cosa ti tocchi ma cosa ti tocchi
basta mi sta trascinando ma sti stronzi
ma veramente mollate mi bastano gli
portano sulla montagna mi danno in
sacrificio assatanato vivo ancora di
missili privacy ai posso anche uscire
tra l'altro fanta ancora qua ma che
cazzo ma questa volta esco affanculo che
poi sono deficienti ma ha lasciato vivo
che posso scappare ma è meglio così
ma il tennis ragazzi è sempre comunque
un grandissimo sport e lo dirò sempre
rega fatemi cucinare qualcosa perché mio
dio sto crepando di fame anche se la fai
bravo zia meno quello perché mi piace la
tristezza di uomo perfetto vai così ma
se assicuri che cotto per bene secondo
me se mangio questa cosa moro zombie
style illudendolo squisite così ecco e
le modelle di victoria's secret stavano
portando adesso che hanno aperto il
negozio hanno perse qua barbie dai
un'occhiata è che intanto vado in giro
bambi devi dare bravo vedi che capisci
che cazzo ti tocchi lo ridà pervertita
una fan culo
minchia chi è cacciatore mamma mi manca
in avatar
tanto posso mangiare per aversi che
tristezza regala un infanzia rovina
tissimo c'è una caverna in caverna lega
fatemi dare un'occhiata alla caverna che
non sono curioso
non ci posso mai morire perché io sono
un pro sono un pro delle caverne non la
fate vi darà un'occhiata e poi esco
cazzo scherzavo scherza la scheda non
esco subito esco subito esco gallon di
merda dove ragazzi
porca [ __ ] cielo dietro lurido
presente muori crepa [ __ ] eva e
così pure che non muore 22 gollum ma
[ __ ] no non ci credo mai nato
ti ammazzo la famiglia a tutti i tuoi
fratelli schifosi ti abbia il tesoro
tela infine il q
niente è stato è stato bello però di
provare a giocare di fare se fanno delle
robe ai cambiamenti e cose ci riprovo di
nuovo anche perché gollum
in realtà io lo amo quindi ragazzi spero
che il video vi sia piaciuto e cava
senza servizio è piaciuto è stata mente
mi piace anche a pagina di facebook e
comune di video a trattare descrizione
se non sarà così distinte noi ci
crediamo non fossero vinto quella
ragazzi
[Musica]